the final vote they could upend a
century-long tradition as the Democratic
National Committee is poised to shake up
the start of its primary calendar
President Biden championed the revamped
lineup ahead of today's full membership
vote supporters say the overhaul
empowers voters who have gone unheard in
Battleground States despite some
divisions over the proposed changes
Democrats are hoping to Showcase Unity
with today's vote Ed O'Keefe is in
Philadelphia what are you hearing Ed
Michelle good to see you the president
vice president we're here last night as
you said and top Democratic leaders are
going to do something today they've
talked about doing for quite some time
rearranging the order in which states
get to choose a president at the expense
of one that has taken the process quite
seriously
President Biden in Philadelphia Friday
night strongly attacked Republicans jobs
are up wages are up inflation is down
and covert no longer controls our lives
but now the extreme maggot Republicans
in the House of Representatives and made
it clear they intend to put it all at
risk his appearance at his first
political event this year had him
sounding like a candidate but aides say
a formal reelection announcement is
still several more weeks away while they
wait Democrats are planning ahead
they're approving a plan to start their
2024 primaries in South Carolina
followed by a combination of New
Hampshire and Nevada three days later
Battlegrounds Georgia and Michigan would
also move up while Iowa punished for its
chaotic 2020 caucus is being pushed
farther back this proposal by President
Biden will reflect the strength of
America's greatest
asset
and that is our diversity the plans
Elevate South Carolina's black voters
Nevada's growing Latino population and
gives earlier attention to two key
Battleground States but the change is
especially stinging to New Hampshire
which has held the first primary since
the 1920s National Democrats believe the
smaller rural mostly white state has
been in the lead for too long New
Hampshire Democratic party chairman Ray
Buckley disagrees it's called shooting
yourself in the foot do they have a
point when they talk about the lack of
diversity in New Hampshire we have made
it diversity a priority here in New
Hampshire and we are supportive of
diversity across the country we're we
are not opposed to bringing in other
states but the fact is that New
Hampshire is going to be the first
that's because New Hampshire is of state
law requiring it hold the first Primary
in the nation National Democrats want
them to drop it but Republican Governor
Chris sununu was also thinking about
running for president says that won't
happen it's an absolute joke it's not
being based on anything to ensure that
the voters in America will have a better
first filter
so if New Hampshire still opts to go
first there's a chance the Democratic
party will say you don't get to seat
delegates at the 2024 convention we'll
see how that goes that's still several
more than a year away
the big thing the president has to worry
about in the next few days is his State
of the Union Address he's going to spend
the weekend putting the final touches on
it and while he sounded awfully partisan
last night AIDS tell us Michelle the
message on Tuesday night is unity
although not official it sounds like the
political season has begun at O'Keefe
thank you